the apparent victory for the president
coming less than 24 hours after former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
pleaded guilty to lying to the FBI Flynn
is cooperating with Special Counsel
Robert molars investigation of Russian
interference in the 2016 election on
Friday President Trump ignored questions
from reporters as he welcomed Libya's
prime minister to the White House
CBS News justice correspondent Jeff
Pegues is in our Washington bureau with
more Jeff good morning good morning
White House lawyer Ty Cobb tried to put
some distance between the president and
the guilty plea by saying that the
charge implicates no one other than
Michael Flynn but Flynn's cooperation
with the special counsel signals that
the Russia investigation is moving
closer to the president's inner circle
Michael Flynn arrived at the courthouse
plead guilty to making false statements
to the FBI once inside a federal judge
asked him if he was doing so willingly
and voluntarily the 58 year old former
Lieutenant General answered with a
simple yes sir according to court papers
Flynn lied to FBI agents about the
details of two phone calls he had with
then Russian ambassador to the US Sergei
Kiss lyac during the presidential
transition CBS News is Lauren Flynn was
directed to make the first call by
president Trump's son-in-law Jared
Kushner described in court papers as a
very senior member of the transition
team on December 22nd 2016 Flynn called
kiss Lee Act to urge Russia to delay or
defeat a United Nations resolution
concerning Israeli settlements a week
later Flynn spoke to kiss lyac again
this time about new sanctions imposed by
the Obama administration on Russia he
relayed to the Ambassador that the Trump
team did not want Russia to escalate the
situation Flynn made that call after
consulting with someone court papers
identify as a senior transition official
CBS News has learned that was Flynn's
deputy katie mcfarland after the second
kiss Lee act called Russian President
Vladimir Putin announced that he would
not retaliate for the u.s. sanctions and
president-elect Trump tweeted Putin was
very smart lock her up Owen was a loyal
Trump surrogate during the campaign but
he was fired as the president's national
security adviser after just 24 days when
it became clear he had also lied to vice
president pence about his communications
with kis lyac pan said publicly said
they did not discuss sanctions
it was strictly coincidental
they had a conversation they did not
discuss anything having to do with the
United States decision to expel
diplomats or
impose a censure against Russia Flynn's
plea deal with the special counsels
office requires him to cooperate with
the investigation
in a statement Flynn said his actions
were wrong and his guilty plea was in
the best interest of my family and of
our country
what does Flynn's cooperation signal
about the direction of this
investigation signals its going forward
and it's moving and advancing very
quickly Peters Eisenberg is a former
federal prosecutor if anyone was going
to be interacting with the Russians or
would know about it it would be Flynn so
if you can get him to talk it would be
worth giving him a great deal
considering the allegations against him
this was a good deal for Flynn who might
have otherwise faced decades behind bars
it was under scrutiny for other alleged
crimes including failing to disclose
payments from Russian backed companies
and trying to orchestrate the kidnapping
of a Turkish cleric in exchange for
fifteen million dollars Alex Jeff you
say this is a good deal for Mike Flynn
what indications do we have about the
level of cooperation he may be offering
to Special Counsel
well in his own statement he said that
he took this plea deal and that he will
be cooperating with the special counsels
investigation Mike Flynn is a unique
individual in this investigation and I
say that because he straddled the
campaign the transition and then the
first few weeks of this White House and
he was at the top levels of the campaign
transition and that White House early on
and so he was in on some of these
top-level discussions and what
investigators are trying to figure out
is why the Russians were so intent on
helping the Trump campaign and whether
any deals were made Jeff you reported
that Jared Kushner directed Flynn to
make contact with the Russian ambassador
about a UN resolution what might this
mean for the president's son-in-law in
terms of this investigation
well Kushner has already been under
scrutiny for example he left about a
hundred meetings off a security
clearance form that he had to fill out a
queue
including meetings with Russians so he's
under scrutiny for that also he was
reportedly in on the conversations when
it came to the firing of former FBI
director James Comey so the scrutiny has
been there on Kushner it now increases
we know that he was interviewed by the
special counsels office early last month
and most of those questions were told
focused on Flint so the heat is on Jared
Kushner as well all right Jeff Pegues
thank you Jeff